the challenges of summer vacation is
making sure there are enough healthy
snacks for everybody to help us with
that we're joined by health expert and
registered dietitian mia
good to have you here in studio i'm so
excited thank you for having me back
always good to have you here yes i'm so
excited to talk about summer snacks and
meals um you know this time of year we
kind of crave lighter meals and snacks
so we're going to start with snack boxes
and these are ones you can take to the
pool so how to build a satisfying snack
box you want to start with fresh fruits
and vegetables i like to use in season
mini bell peppers sugar snap peas then i
like a little bit of crunch so these are
sweet potato chips they're by jackson's
made with sweet potatoes heirloom sweet
potatoes non-gmo sourced from farmers
made with coconut and avocado oil so you
want to look at the oils that your chips
are made with these are all vegan gluten
free grain free free of artificial
flavors you can find them at sprout
smith's sam's club this is a carolina
barbecue if you want to try yeah
absolutely i love these such a good
alternative to regular chips
yeah and sweet potatoes are you know
more nutritious than regular potatoes so
it's a great way to satisfy that craving
so add some crunch to your snack box and
then add a nutritious dip so you can do
salsa guacamole i love hummus because
it's adds kind of a creaminess and good
plant-based protein and fiber this is
the fresh cravings hummus you can find
it at smithson walmart this is made with
chilean extra virgin olive oil chickpeas
savory tahini there's a honey jalapeno
you can do classic everything bagel
get creative and so you have a healthy
dip
kind of a crunchy snack fruits and
vegetables in your box you mentioned
coconut oil or avocado oil yes are there
some sweet potato chips that are made in
other kinds of oils yes so
um you know avocado oil and coconut oil
are kind of like my healthy oils that i
look for especially with chips so like
canola oil kind of like those ultra
process oils you kind of want to avoid
and so that can really make a rake
potato chips and french fries is the oil
that they're made with okay so i love
avocado oil it has a high smoke point so
it's great for you know making potato
chips fried oven baked fries so i use
avocado oil all the time okay because
those good for you fats good to know all
right what else we got so these are two
ingredient energy bars really fun to
make so
what you're going to do is you're going
to add a date paste about one cup of
date paste and then one cup of processed
nuts so i'm using pistachios wonderful
pistachios i work with them these are a
good source of plant protein and fiber
complete plant-based protein most
plant-based proteins are not complete so
you're getting all those essential amino
acids you're gonna mix that together and
then you're going to get kind of a
batter that you can shape into bars and
you know you can go sweet or savory
there's barbecue
chili roasted honey roasted and i just
love these because you're getting that
kind of good carbohydrates from the
dates that natural sweetness without
added sugar and the plant protein the
date paste has already come like that um
you can buy it pre-made like that or you
can make it in a food processor it took
me like 30 seconds and one tip is you
can soak the dates to soften them and
they'll process
really easily terrific all right we've
got about 45 seconds here
so antioxidant small water this is made
with palm wonderful i work with them you
know
pomegranate juice is an excellent source
of antioxidants they have four times the
antioxidants on average as green tea
so they're you know healthy fridge
staple this is great you can add some
fruits and herbs to your water and
that's a great way to stay hydrated and
then pizza everyone's favorite summer
meal and these are actually plant-based
they're made by daia they
make plant-based eating easy all seven
flavors made with a thin crispy crust um
herb tomato sauce plant-based cheese and
one of those at smith's walmart and
whole foods pair that with like a side
salad and you have a great summer meal
great ideas and i love this power bar
yeah yeah
really really good all right mia good to
have you here thanks so much for
dropping in
rocky
all right